bonsoir acacias que doit-on retenir de
cette prise de parole du premier
ministre et de ses ministres
eh bien ces familles beaucoup d'annoncés
sur les vaccins comme on s'y attendait
mais tout d'abord un point sur la
situation épidémique la circulation du
virus reste préoccupante on est bien
loin des 5000 contamination par jour qui
correspondent à une épidémie maîtriser
la pression sur les hôpitaux restent
fortes
et puis cette inquiétude l'apparition de
deux variantes du virus un sud africain
et un britannique ce dernier est de 40 à
70% plus contagieux il existe deux
clusters de ce variant un en bretagne en
ile de france il faut absolument éviter
sa diffusion
vous parliez tout à l'heure des lieux
qui resteront fermés les cinémas salles
de spectacles les remontées mécaniques
tous ces lieux dont vont le rester il y
aura un point d'étape le 20 janvier pour
étudier une réouverture potentiel le
début février donc toujours pas de
certitude mais le secteur sera soutenue
avec diverses z
et puis également le fameux couvre feu
de 18h qui concerne 15 départements se
poursuivra il sera peut être étendu à 10
supplémentaires et puis ce qu'on
attendait évidemment la clarification du
plan vaccinal par jean castex on écoute
la campagne vaccinale contre lacko vide
a commencé le 27 décembre dernier va se
poursuivre dans les mois à venir
elle suscite des attentes qui sont
légitimes mais aussi des interrogations
qui le sont tout autant
en revanche elle a donné lieu ces
derniers jours de la part de certains à
des propos et des critiques parfois
outrancier oui c'est vrai notre prof de
vaccination a démarré plus lentement que
dans d'autres pays ce décalage
s'explique par notre choix de respecter
les principes et de priorités qui nous
ont été fixées par la haute autorité de
santé
alors il y a le problème de
l'autorisation des vaccins donc on sait
bien que la france a commandé 200
millions de vaccins mais ils ne seront
livrées que tout au long
de 2021 il ya des problèmes de
production bien évidemment mais il ya
aussi donc la question de l'autorisation
seul le kaiser était jusqu'aux jusqu'ici
autorisées en france le modern à l'est
depuis hier alors il y aura cinquante
mille doses de vaccins livrés dès lundi
et puis des millions dans les mois à
venir ce qui permettra on l'espère à la
france de rattraper son retard de
vaccination en retard par rapport à
d'autres pays d'europe
il ya six ans entre ils seront bientôt
ouverts indice il ya deux semaines six
centres de vaccination en france dans
les départements et puis il y a
également cette question des du passage
aux autres étapes de vaccination qui va
s'accélérer en écoutant castex les
personnes de plus de 75 ans pourront se
faire vacciner à partir de lundi 18
janvier ces vaccinations se dérouleront
dans des centres de vaccination un
centre par département a déjà été
ouverts donc sans sur le territoire à
partir de lundi prochain
il y en aura trois cents puis six ans
progressivement jusqu'à la fin du mois
de janvier alors un point positif tout
de même à le système de dépistage
fonctionne très bien après mme un
cafouillage et pénurie ainsi il est
totalement gratuit contre 100 euros en
allemagne pour un dépistage et jusqu'à
350 euros en grande bretagne pour un pcr
est ainsi 3 5 millions de personnes ont
pu se faire vacciner la semaine avant
noël